alors qu'à new york on prépare les
commémorations du 11-septembre les
professionnels du tourisme constatent
une chute très sensible des réservations
c'est vrai dans l'hôtellerie mais
surtout dans le transport aérien
alain de chalvron ground zero est devenu
le site le plus visité de new york les
touristes viennent des quatre coins du
monde pour voir où entrevoir le trou
béant où s'élevaient les deux tours du
world trade center
les petits malins en profitent pour
faire un commerce de souvenirs un peu
morbide mais il est vrai que l'exemple
vient d'en haut puisque la ville de new
york indique elle même aux visiteurs le
meilleur point de vue best view sur le
trou curieux mais pas téméraire ses
touristes
s'il se pressent aujourd'hui ils
devraient être beaucoup moins nombreux
le 11 septembre même pour le premier
anniversaire des attentats en europe
ensemble septembre ces pylônes ont donc
peut-être que j'aurai un peu de mal
j'aimerais venir le 11 septembre ici
parce que c'est un anniversaire morbide
2faites l'aéroport kennedy devrait ce
jour là connaître une activité ralentie
de nombreuses compagnies européennes ont
d'ores et déjà annulé une bonne partie
de leurs vols jusqu'à un tiers pour
british airways 2 pour air france il y a
une très nette diminution ce jour là
nous avons enregistré beaucoup moins de
réservations depuis plusieurs semaines
les gens ne veulent pas voyager une date
aussi marquée que celle là les hôtels
sont vides pour ce jour-là un hôtel par
exemple sur 127 chambres en à fraisses
de réserve et on dresse les friands mais
les gens ne viennent pas les européens
surtout en vérité les autorités de new
york n'essaye pas vraiment d'attirer les
visiteurs pour le 11 septembre
ce jour là les new-yorkais ont envie de
rester entre eux